it's a blue state spending spree
courtesy of you the american taxpayer
president biden bailing out states with
350 billion dollars even though
many don't need it for example liberal
california just announced a 75 billion
dollar budget surplus
but it's still getting 27 billion
dollars from
biden you governor gavin newsom is now
sending stimulus checks to two-thirds of
the residents
in his state and on the east coast new
york city mayor bill de blasio is being
accused of spending billions in covet
cash
like a drunken sailor so jesse
we found a good thing about california
getting a check
yeah i might have to move out there i
could sure use the money with these hot
gas prices let me tell you
it is funny to look at the republican
governors who are out there
managing land and following the science
and
opening up schools and trying to balance
the budget and
and then you have the media just calls
him racist
and then you have democrat governors all
they do is spend and they say they care
and that's all they do surplus spend
deficit
spend we're in a recession spend we're
in a boom spend
hey if there's a problem on the border
you spend in guatemala
it's so e if i wish i could be
reincarnated as a democrat
so easy just spend and anybody that
disagrees
they're a racist
dana this is exactly what republicans
warned about this is why they
voted against the covet relief package
because it's a lot of it's a big waste
of money going to democrats
well this is the other thing about the
gavin newsom piece so he announces that
he's going to send additional stimulus
checks to everybody
right before there's going to be an
election about his recall
and if you remember when president trump
and i also disagreed with this right he
wanted to put out those stimulus checks
right away right before the election
wanted his name on it and wanted a
letter to go to every american and the
democrats cried foul
well the same is true here and another
point on this
when they passed that coveted relief
bill with that money in it they said
the democrat said that states could not
use any of that money
to go towards tax relief for their
citizens
now 13 attorneys general are suing the
federal government saying you can't tell
us what we can
can and can't do in terms of taxing our
own people
but if you apparently you can't give it
back in the form of tax relief
but you can give out stimulus checks
that doesn't make any sense
yeah greg maybe de blasio can use some
of that money to clean up your
neighborhood after it was looted
well that's a good point uh i think i
got a good uh a good
motto build bribes better because this
is what it's about it's bribing people
that's what
that's what everybody's doing and don't
insult drunken sailors by comparing them
to bill de blasio
so okay this is why people are leaving
california if you go outside to the
boardwalks that you used to enjoy maybe
a decade ago they're swamped
with derelicts some are very violent
some are mentally ill and fresh
freshly released and they're co-mingling
with others and they're committing
they're committing crime including hate
crimes against asians
yet california you get a surplus they
could solve everything with that money
if they wanted to but for some reason
they don't you bring up de blasio
this is a really interesting thing
that's going on it's infuriating to
somebody like me who lives here
but in new york city right now you have
a mayoral race
in which the left-wing candidates are
running on a get
tough on crime platform so what does
this tell you
the writing is on the wall and it's in
blood and they realize that it's not
getting better and as the summer gets
hotter
as axios pointed out they are they are
are counting on more violence
just like what we saw in times square
two days ago when a child was injured
people were shot in broad daylight at
times square but we couldn't talk about
it
it's left-wing policies that are
destroying these cities
and people keep re-electing them
they do juan why do they keep doing that
well let me get this straight there was
never anybody shot in times square under
a republican
okay all right i mean if you believe
that fine um
that's so silly i mean i don't know what
to say to it
it's it's it's it's just constantly it
is
what you said was silly so here's the
thing giuliani
greatest tourist attraction in the world
right do you remember that
yeah right did you remember that yeah
okay is that not true what we have
i it's not true okay not true
of new york and i'm you know you know
you talk about
crime crackdowns i mean you know what
about that
okay let's go back i'll go back to the
stimulus cause i'm much more interested
in that yes
i am i am taken by the idea that you see
republicans
out there right now campaigning going
home to town hall meetings and saying
taking credit as if they had voted
for this package and you said wait wait
a second republicans didn't vote for
who's doing it but they want to take
credit for it now
and the thing about this is when you
look at the criticism either
of stimulus or unemployment benefits and
that's the big argument right now you
know why do we have enhanced
unemployment is it driving down
the number of people who willing to go
back to work it just strikes me as
almost
insulting to the american people and
saying somehow we don't want to work
that people don't want jobs people i
meet all want to work and all want
better jobs and i just you know but it
often times gets into
anti-immigrant stuff why is the new
jersey governor
spending money on stimulus and
unemployment benefits
for illegal immigrants well remember
these are the janitors
these are the truck drivers these are
the people that
have delivered essential services to us
they're our neighbors
we don't have to make it about that hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else